Eu ultimamente tenho me estressado muito
é muito normal você passa da casa dos 20
anos você eu acho que a vida é isso você
vai vivendo e vai só percebendo quantas
mais coisas você consegue ficar
estressado quando acontece você começa a
entender mais coisas também por exemplo
adolescente quando eu era adolescente eu
não entendia porque que todo mundo não
suportava adolescente eu ficava daquele
jeito que adolescente fica é difícil
cara a pressão é muito cara This is real
this is me Eu não me importo que a
sociedade não me aceita eu odeio meus
pais e a minha família eu não sou nesse
planeta aí você cresce e vê de outra
perspectiva a você fala ah é por isso
que ninguém me queria por perto